hello and welcome to my webinar
on anatomy of a nucleic acid sample
preparation
my name is katherine meckling and i'm a
technology development
molecular workflow scientist for
millipore sigma
milpor sigma is the life science
business of
mark kgaa domsdot germany and operates
as millipore sigma
in the us and canada
today's webinar i will outline sample
preparation
through a short introduction before
discussing common methods used by
scientists
i'll be highlighting workflows for
genomic dna isolation
finally i'm excited to introduce you to
a new technology
coming soon from the poor sigma called
general e
single spin technology
anatomy is a study of the structure or
internal workings of something after
sample collection there are five
key workflow decisions a scientist makes
in regards to their sample preparation
the first step is homogenization of the
sample
mechanical disruption by using a pestle
or
bee beading is often used for tough
samples such as
animal or plant tissues however samples
like
cells or blood can be pelleted before
lysis
the next step is breaking open the
sample and digesting any unwanted
biomolecules through
that lysis step for nucleic acid sample
preparations
typically a lysis buffer is added that
will assist
with breaking into the cells proteases
like the ubiquitous protein ace k are
used to digest the proteins that can
degrade the nucleic acid
optionally if assessing for dna
sometimes an incubation of rnas is
performed or if
rna rna is assessed a dnase
is used purification is the choice of
method
for separating and isolating the
biomolecule of interest
there are several ways of performing
this process and i will dive into some
of the more common workflows later in
this presentation
modification is the process of making
changes to the nucleic acid
that allows for the final step which is
assessment
there are now methods where scientists
will amplify their nucleic acid
by pcr directly after lysis however
however for unbiased assessment
uh results from up here purification
step is still required
most scientists group lysis and
purification together for sample
preparation
as many off-the-shelf products exist to
address these needs
however before i go deeper into the
different methods of purification
it is important to think about some of
the key pain points
about sample preparation that can impact
downstream sample modification and
assessment
the two key drivers for downstream
failure
is poor quality and poor yield this is
due to
inherent variability within individual
samples
as well as variability across the
different sample types
typically optimization is required from
the end user
in order to validate for their sample
type additionally
incomplete lysis can be a driver to help
reduce
to not help but to cause those reduced
yields
nucleic acids degrade over time and that
could potentially lead to reduced
fragment length
and also impact those overall yields
additionally you want to be careful of
those carryover
process contaminants from sample
preparation such as binding salts and
organic solvents that can have
detrimental impacts on downstream
processes and it is important to be
mindful
of these factors one of the oldest
techniques
still used by scientists today for
nucleic acid purification
is phase separation and cleanup this is
commonly called
phenyl chloroform isolation the nucleic
acids separate
due to preferences of a hydrophilic
environment
of the aqueous phase compared to that of
the organic solvent
guanidium thiocyanate aka tropic agent
is added to the organic phase to aid in
the denaturation
of proteins such as those that strongly
bind nucleic acids
or those that degrade rna under acidic
conditions
such as between phs 4 and 6
dna partitions into the organic phase
while rna remains in the aqueous phase
under neutral conditions such as those
between 7 and 8
both dna and rna will partition into the
aqueous phase
that aqueous phase is then collected and
followed by a ethanol or
isopropanol precipitation to clean up
the organic solvents used to isolate the
nucleic acids
from the sample lysate these
organic solvents can also have
downstream impact the downstream
applications and it's kind of strange to
use organic
solvents to clean up organic solvents
the nucleic acid is finally crashed in a
pellet using a salt and washed multiple
times with organic solvents
the ethanol or isopropanol before
re-spending in
a storage buffer
one of the most common methods for
nucleic acid isolation
is using silica spin columns this is
widely used
out of convenience where commercially
available kits can be performed
safely without a fume hood the silica
membrane
is positively charged and therefore
easily bind the negatively charged
nucleic acids
again katropic salts assist with
denaturing of the proteins
from the nucleic acid and also assist in
the binding steps to the membrane
before the sample was washed with an
ethanol solution and eluded in a final
storage buffer
and so began the age of bind wash elute
another common method is using magnetic
beads
these are very similar to the silica
columns
and silica magnetic beads are positively
charged and therefore
again easily bind those negatively
charged nucleic acids
again chaotropic salts are used to
assist in denaturing the proteins from
the nucleic acid
and assist in the bead binding steps
before the sample is washed with an
ethanol solution
and finally eluded in a storage buffer
this process is widely adopted due to
its ease to be automated over silica
spin columns
thus making it popular with high
throughput labs
i hope by now you've noticed a pattern
where
if it is either phase separation and
cleanup silicon
magnetic beads or silk spin columns the
process can be tedious
with binding and washing of the nucleic
acid
tube handling can be prone to human
error and these methods typically run
the
risk of cross-contamination yet what if
those
bind and wash steps could be eliminated
from the workflow
and now i get to introduce you to the
general
e single spin technology where the
nucleic acid is purified in a single
spin
this is eliminating all of the bind and
wash steps
resulting in reduced tube handling
and a safer and more efficient way of
handling your sample you may be thinking
you cannot just eliminate the bind and
wash steps
however by using a negative
chromatography method
it is possible instead of binding the
nucleic acid and running the risk of
insufficient binding
or non-specific binding of your sample
negative chromatography uses
size exclusion to fractionate the
components of the sample by size
this eliminates process biases
associated with
binding nucleic acids to a membrane or
to a bead
larger biomolecules like nucleic acid
flow more readily through a resin bed
while smaller contaminants
are absorbed and retained by differing
migration speeds through the resin beads
and take a longer time to make it
through as you can see through this
graphic the nucleic acids bypass the
beads
while the sample contaminants are
small enough to fit within the beads and
are absorbed thus taking a scenic route
clearing the sample and packing the
resin before loading the superdatan
prevents cellular debris from eluding in
the final sample
these workflow changes provide three key
advantages
over silica simplified workflow superior
performance
and reduced waste due to eliminating a
lot of the
tube handling steps and of course no
more kaotropic cells
or ethanol
insufficient lysis can be a setup for
failure from the start
that's why we took a more targeted
approach with general
e smartlice protease mixes these
reagents were chosen for two specific
reasons
one their efficiency to work in a
non-kaotropic environment
and two their optimization for their
sample type
for example animal tissues and bacterial
cell culture samples require totally
different
lysis strengths using a sample specific
approach
helps cut down on incubation times and
no k tropes in the lysis buffer means
no chaotros in the final sample
additionally
preparing the spin column for
purification can be
performed simultaneously to this step
for even more workflow time savings
but let's take a closer look at the
column itself preparing the column for
use is a simple process
a separate collection tube is used to
collect the void volume
from the column and can be reused since
it actually never touches the sample
additionally the cap should be loosened
a quarter of a turn or a cap punching
tool can be used to prevent
prevent a vacuum from forming within the
column
the fir beyond that you need to snap off
the bottom closure so the sample has a
place to go
additionally you need to resuspend the
bead matrix
by a simple vortex step so that they
are re-suspended and that they pack more
evenly
during the column preparation step and
after
setting the column the column buffer is
removed and this lamp may or may not be
observed due to that lovely
centrifugation step
now you can choose your own workflow you
can simply
load your sample directly into the
column without opening the purification
column
just use the general e single spin cap
puncher device
this helps reduce cross contamination by
keeping the sample contained between
transfer steps while this tool is meant
to work specifically
with general e purification columns it
is not required for purification
all you have to do is load your sample
directly onto the resin bead after
unscrewing the cap just remember to keep
the cap loosened
quarter turn if no hole is punched in
the cap
one spin and you're done and now you
have a general e
purified nucleic acid
remember those pesky organic solvents
and kaotropic salts from previous
nucleic acid workflows shown here is an
example
of spectrophotometric data comparison
between silica based protocols and the
general eu single spin workflow
in purple is the sample purified by the
different methods
and blue or teal is the purification
without the sample being added
in red is the sample without any
processed contaminants
and in yellow is the back background or
the blank
for this analysis as you can see in this
example
the process contaminants can be observed
from the silica method
in the od 230 range
spinning the sample only once has other
advantages as well
high molecular weight genomic dna is
critical for certain downstream
applications
such as next generation sequencing or
electron microscopy
silica-based purification methods rely
on multiple spins that can shear
the nucleic acid shown here is four
replicate samples
purified either using a silica column or
a general e column
as you can see there is more full length
product on the electrophoresis gel
for the general e purified nucleic acids
additionally the smaller fragments that
could potentially be due to sharing of
the nucleic acids
are often included in yield calculations
and can give
a false sense of how much template is
being used in downstream workflows
without adding process contaminants to
the sample purification
downstream modifications and assessments
are more reliable
and it makes sense polymerases and
restriction enzymes
have preferred buffers and salts and do
not like
organic solvents these factors can
impact the thermodynamics of a reaction
shown here is an example of qpcr
of mouse kidney tissue assessing for a
housekeeping gene
from genomic dna isolated by the two
methods
silica or general e single spin the
silica isolated genomic dna
has a higher ct value indicating either
there's inhibition in the reaction
or there's inaccurate quantitation of
the template
being added to the reaction
the e in general e highlights several
eco-friendly improvements
the first of course is that there's no
more
hazardous liquid waste and this is done
by eliminating the binding and wash
steps that have those
ethanol and keotropic salts additionally
we re-thought about the packaging so
this has sustainable packaging
in mind where the box in the insert is
made of 70
recyclable content additionally this is
the first product to have compostable
materials used for packaging and that's
what all of our columns
are packaged in plus since it's a
simplified workflow and there's fewer
steps
there's a higher savings in energy costs
and you can actually measure the waste
prevention
on how much plastic between the two
workflows
where if i take all the pipette tips all
the tubes used in the workflow
to isolate as well as the column
weight of the column itself if i take
the measurements of
purifying one sample compared to
purifying the other there's a 55
reduction in plastic weight that is
commonly
costs users for disposal
and here are they
finally there's these key applications
that we are targeting with the
initial launch of this product um it's
being targeted initially for genomic dna
from sample types such as whole blood
cell culture
animal tissue and plant tissue we have
supporting products
as well the cap puncher some ffpe
d-parasition solution which is also a
safer
solution since um it's commonly used for
xylene which is
very unsafe um so this is not a xylene
um deep peripheration solution so it's a
lot safer to use
we also have a tissue stabilizer and an
rna gel loading buffer
plus you can if you're not isolating
directly from
a lysate if you're just trying to purify
or deplete an impurity from your
sample we also have these cleanup kits
that are
also available and you can use our handy
dandy
selection tool here in order to choose
for your cleanup type
we have only just begun but we already
have several products for you to try
these products will be available very
soon in just a couple weeks
so i really hope you get a chance to
check them out
thank you again i hope you enjoyed this
presentation
and i look forward to your questions